for three weeks now our state's test
positivity rate has continued
to decrease hospitalizations also down
let's go quickly here for the numbers
you can see here
on our board nearly 900 cases added in
the last 24 hours 39 covet 19 related
deaths were reported as well as we
move forward here i want to point your
attention here to this number almost
700 new cases new infections are right
here
from clark county 32 people have passed
away about 204
000 people have recovered from the virus
here in southern nevada that's 93.9
percent of
all reported cases well governor steve
sisalek addressed a
problem today he says is causing
confusion and
unfairness in southern nevada during a
taped message he says the state's most
vulnerable and minority communities are
not getting the covet 19 vaccines they
need
to help stop the problem the governor is
calling for a fairness
inequity initiative which will be led by
our state's immunization team to get
southern nevada
back on track every time a group is
allowed to be vaccinated who is not
eligible
those doses are being taken away from
someone's grandma or grandpa
or a frontline worker who has been
showing up every day throughout this
pandemic
under this initiative clark county will
work with the emergency management and
the southern nevada
health district to clarify priority and
support fairness
across all communities he added that he
doesn't blame the community but the
leadership of the distribution
who has an ethical responsibility
with the second dose now available some
of you have been asking us is it okay if
i schedule
my second dose a few days before or
after the target date
you have to wait three weeks before you
can get your second pfizer dose
and four weeks for the moderna shot the
state says there
is some leeway generally two days before
and
two days after so don't worry if you can
get your appointment exactly on the
target date
the best practice is to get that second
dose as close
to that date as you can